me in the past i have the very fun job
of running growth for rstudio cloud
in terms of housekeeping for today's
event we're going to have a guest
presenter run through a presentation for
the first half of today's session and
then we're going to jump into a q a for
the second half
now i have a colleague on the back end
who's going to be hopefully juggling
some questions as they trickle in via
chat and if you need to leave early
please don't worry we will be recording
this
and please keep in mind that the focus
of these events are to address the
questions most important to all of you
now with that being said i'm super
excited to introduce today's guest dr
brian anderson associate dean and
professor at university of missouri
kansas city
pete thanks so much appreciate it
well thank you everybody and and welcome
i'm so pleased that uh
you all take the time to to join us and
and pete thank you and and the team at
our studio and our studio cloud for for
giving me the opportunity to to chat
about a topic that uh i'm very
passionate about but also one that as a
as a institution we are very much still
uh working through and still addressing
uh you know our own path forward i think
it kind of reflects the uh the very
rapid pace and development
you know in this field and so i'm
looking forward to to sharing some
thoughts about uh the challenges that we
uh have identified as we look to move
towards a kind of a cloud-centric
solution for our undergraduate and
graduate programs
and also talk about some of the
opportunities ahead and then you know
certainly uh the chance to uh to hear
from you all uh answer some questions
and have some dialogue so
why don't we go ahead and get started
with
the presentation so
uh
in my role as uh executive associate
dean at the block school i oversee all
of our degree programs and so this
notion of how do we leverage
new and emerging technologies to teach
topics you know certainly analytics at
scale is very much
in my area of responsibility
so let me uh let me give a little bit of
context about the block school and the
university of missouri kansas city
so the university of missouri kansas
city is part of the university of
missouri system there are four campuses
in our system you may be familiar with
our larger sister campus the
in columbia mizzou
we serve the kansas city area in the
kansas city region so by carnegie
classification we are a research two
school so we are a research centric
school
but we also are very much a public urban
research university school
so as
part of that mission
our student population very much
reflects the diversity of
the kansas city region so for example we
have a very large percentage of our
students
that are first generation college
students we have a large percentage of
our students that come from historically
underrepresented communities
our student population reflects uh you
know significant heterogeneity in
socioeconomic background and so when we
think about
leveraging technologies it's important
to kind of keep that student body
population in mind
dribbling down a little bit more the
block school is what we would consider
to be kind of a medium
sized business schools we have about 2
000 total students our single largest
degree program is our professional mba
which has about 600
students in that program
we focus on business analytics and i
think that that
context is important here
most of what you would think of as kind
of core knowledge core technologies
would be very similar in you know kind
of a standard uh computer science intro
course or a
you know kind of a basic undergraduate
statistics course or core graduate
statistics course but it's really taught
from an analytics frame or excuse me a
business frame so it's grounded in a
business conversation
and addressing business problems and i
think that's that's important to keep in
mind that everything really kind of
needs to tie to our core business
contacts i think an analogy might be say
a health analytics space where the
statistics the analytics coursework
behind it would reflect very common
elements but it would be taught in a
health
frame so we offer
analytic specializations what would
effectively be like a
major
we also have a smaller interest area and
then we have a graduate certificate
and then the last contextual piece that
i think is very important is
the employment base within kansas city
so most of our students come from the
kansas city region and they will work in
the kansas city region
and kansas city is is very fortunate
that we have a very strong and
diversified economic base our largest
single sector is healthcare but that's
still only about a fifth of
the economy here in kansas city and i
think that's important for us because as
we think about preparing students
with
analytic skill sets it's important that
they are likely to serve in a variety of
different verticals
it would be a disservice to our students
for example if we focused on one
particular context and so it's important
that the skill sets that we provide and
the training that we provide really
reflect the heterogeneity of employment
that our students are likely to have
here in the kansas city region so that's
just a little bit of context but let's
let's jump in and talk about the
problems that we're trying to solve
because this really frames
why
we are looking towards the cloud
for
uh teaching analytics at scale and and i
would put all of these questions
with a pretty similar
ranking right and so
as we think about leveraging technology
to teach at scale we need to address
all of these
all of these challenges so you know
first and foremost relevant and
responsive coursework you know r python
sql
the
you know common technologies that you
find say in more of a software
engineering or computer science type
career field we're going to see those
same kind of technologies uh among our
employers so we need to ensure that we
are providing students with coursework
that aligns to employer expectations
the second bullet point for us is very
important this was a strategic decision
that we made and i think it's important
from an academic standpoint
that schools make this very purposeful
choice
in our
case it was we want to train business
professionals
in data and analytics literacy
that is
in contrast to we're going to train data
scientists
in business literacy so our content and
our coursework is really meant to
provide a baseline level of knowledge
and understanding and exposure to
analytics
skill sets and technologies
with the assumption that the vast
majority of our graduates are not going
to work in analytics specific
fields so for example you might say an
accounting student the accounting field
is very much driven today with an
analytics
background
but first and foremost they are
accountants and they need to be cpas and
so it's giving a cpa
training in analytics
to help that individual
industry
in general
but
for us being a public urban research
university
we are very cognizant of the
heterogeneity in technology skill sets
that our students come to us with
so we will have some students that have
very strong technology skills they've
had exposure with programming in high
school for example they have they have
strong mathematics backgrounds and we
will have other students that did not
have that opportunity
at high school and so they are coming to
us
with a more modest technology background
that would also be true in our graduate
programs as well we might have
individuals that are you know working as
software developers and so they are very
comfortable you know with technology and
learning new technology we'll also have
you know individuals that may be coming
from a non-profit administration
background and have had very little
exposure to technology so
lowering the cost
and the barrier to learning new
technology
is a very important consideration for
our context
from a school perspective
then keeping costs reasonable
for technology adoption is certainly
also important
the
criteria are the the
uh rapid increase in technology budgets
particularly in the last couple of years
as so many universities shifted
uh to uh you know greater percentage of
online teaching
or other digitalization
tools has dramatically increased the
share of the technology budget from a
university standpoint
and so areas in which we can keep
cost growth reasonable
and lowering technology complexity is an
important consideration
so the last two
pieces i think tie very well together in
that looking for solutions that address
core curriculum and that core curriculum
might be
say a course that has
you know 400 students per year taught
across potentially eight sections with
two or three faculty members and so
having
that within course experience taught at
a larger scale while also being able to
uh provide opportunities for students
that want to take deeper dives into more
technically advanced
concepts to have a similar consistent
experience
so just real quick let me talk about the
current solutions because i think this
really reflects where
most universities and most business
schools
are
first and foremost there's a not just a
requirement but an assumption
for students and employers that
microsoft excel
and competency with excel will be
a
an expectation for a business school
curriculum and so every business student
needs to have a baseline competency in
microsoft excel
for finance and accounting students in
particular these areas where microsoft
excel is a
heavy part
of
employer expectations
these students have to have
you know a fairly sophisticated
um
uh training and exposure to microsoft
excel and that's that's not going away
and i think that's important we keep in
mind there's always going to be this
technology
that will be a required element of the
student experience
but then outside of that you know sas r
some legacy spss a little bit of stata
we have and we'll talk about this a
little bit more we have started using
rstudio cloud for some of our graduate
courses and we're continuing to expand
those and we've had quite a bit of
success with that uh python you know
certainly in the data science community
python has
you know been you know very uh you know
not just emerging but
you know very prominent technology for
some time
um
we're just now kind of seeing interest
among employers to have um
employees having a kind of at least a
little bit of exposure and understanding
of python and then from a data
visualization standpoint tableau and
power bi are by far the dominant
platforms that we find in
an industry for our employer partners
and you know having students having
exposure to
those
software tools is an important
consideration so i think this is this is
important to kind of note that
even as we look at
leveraging cloud solutions to teach at
scale it's
part of a suite of technology tools
it's not to the point nor do we really
imagine it becoming the one solution
that allows us to accommodate
all of our student needs
right but by the same token if we can
minimize
the number of software tools that
students are exposed to and are expected
to learn while still addressing that
relevant and responsive coursework then
that's a very powerful value proposition
for the school
and so where where would we like to go
uh as we think about you know analytics
instruction at scale and so this would
be at scale would mean
you know we've got 2 000 students that
are going to be taking a variety of
analytics courses every year
what we'd really like to
avoid is direct installations on
student and school computers
and that that really leads to a
cloud-centric solution that addresses a
number of
student issues one things like tech
support and just the hurdle rate if you
will of
spending class time to
you know install software troubleshoot
software that's directly
installed it also reflects
changes in particularly among graduate
students where they are using
uh whether that's you know laptop
whether it's a tablet or something that
is being provided by their employer
and so because of that they're allowed
to use that employer-provided laptop for
school work but they can't install
software on it
and so this is where for
a good portion of those students
you know the ability to offer a solution
in the cloud really is an important part
of the value proposition
it needs to be laptop and tablet
agnostic so it cannot be tied to a
particular
hardware requirement or a particular
operating system requirement so whether
that's a chromebook whether that's
you know mac osx or it's a windows
environment it needs to be agnostic it
needs to allow for that consistent
student experience
and allow for incorporation of multiple
languages and again it's part of that
part of that workflow
situation where students are still going
to be expected to learn multiple
technologies so for example
you might have a course project that
is
you know drawing from microsoft excel
spreadsheets where a student is going to
manipulate
wrangle and do modeling in our studio
cloud and then
a product of that would be exported for
visualizations through microsoft or
through uh tableau for example those
kinds of projects and workflows and
making it easy for faculty to develop
those kinds of you know very immersive
very experiential projects are are very
important so this is where we'd like to
go but we're not there yet and we're not
there yet because of a variety of
challenges and so let me uh let me kind
of shift a little bit and talk about
some of these challenges and i've split
these off
in financial technical and then faculty
considerations
so the first off it is very important in
this context to address the financial
considerations and and here there's kind
of two different approaches one if the
school is going to be buying the
technology
and that could be that the school is is
absorbing the cost of the technology
purchases
just out of an operating budget for
example or if they're going to pass on
that cost in the form of a
fee to students but ultimately the
school becomes the purchaser so here are
some of the challenges if the school is
going to be the one buying the licensing
you know the first is flexibility
in
the licensing agreement things that lock
down or lock up into exclusive
relationships
those can be more of a challenge
for
universities to
buy into and there's a variety of of
reasons for that but the ability to have
some flexibility in how they structure
the licensing agreement and how it might
conform within the context of other
university
licensing and licensing rules is is
fairly important i think this is this is
the
flexibility on the part more of vendors
than it is
on the part of the universities because
in many cases particularly for public
universities in the united states in
particular there's a number of
public
regulations and state laws that governs
what a university can actually do and so
the vendor might desire to
um
you know have a licensing agreement that
looks a particular way but the
university simply can't because they're
prohibited under a state law and so
having that flexibility is going to be
is pretty important the scalability
issue i think is also
you know a really important question and
that also relates to that per seat
licensing question so
from the standpoint of
if you're going to offer
you know say in our case we're going to
have 2 000
students well we might have situations
where
one student might have multiple courses
so it's
you know it's not just per student but
it's per student seat in a variety of
courses but we may not know
what that demand actually is until we're
very close to the start of the term and
so the ability to scale and adjust
very quickly
in response to not just enrollment but
student demand is an important
consideration
it's also important to note that most
university driven
licensing agreements you know reflect
more of an enterprise type approach
to
software licensing and so that would be
the more you buy the less you pay per
seat
and so
when the school is the purchaser
having that understanding that we're
really kind of approaching this from an
enterprise
mindset
is that you know is an important
consideration and that can be a
challenge because
we're talking about potentially very
large software purchases and those you
know inevitably require additional time
effort and energy to navigate through
the purchasing process
another
you know way to look at a financial
challenge is if the student is going to
be the one
purchasing the software and and by the
student as the purchaser i mean they're
going to be the ones who
make the buy
with the vendor
itself so whether that's credit card or
electronic check or something the
university is not involved in any way in
the actual transaction
and i use this term
sesame street simple and sesame street
simple it does not necessarily mean you
know a dumbed down experience it means
a exceptionally clear and easy
way for students to
purchase the license that they need
with a caveat that
if you're going to
do this successfully and roll this out
you are likely to have multiple
semesters and multiple courses
that a student might be
involved with so let me give you an
example if you have a student who in a
given term is taking two different
analytics
courses
that student may understandably
say
i i just want to buy
you know like you know buy use for
one semester and be able to use it
across all of my courses as opposed to
paying for both courses to use the same
software product now that could be you
know certainly addressable but it is and
it is an important consideration and
then if the student is going to use that
software across multiple semesters then
making it very easy to either renew a
license
or being able to buy a license for a
duration of a program for example but
regardless of what's
a purchasing approach is used it has to
be simple
and then you know certainly the cost you
know if if you're already asking
students to purchase a very expensive
textbook or you know they they are
already
you know experiencing some financial
stress because of additional cost of
fees and and other requirements to
engage with a course
then
an expensive software purchase on top of
that can create an additional barrier
and create some additional friction
points
all right so those those are some of the
financial challenges
and then it's important to think about
some technology challenges too you know
student privacy and data network
security you know are are
not not only very salient but in so many
cases are really driving
purchase and adoption decisions so
any kind of technology that is going to
touch student data in some way
there is an expectation for a very high
degree of security and data integrity
now i think in a lot of ways this
actually supports cloud-based
solutions
that are you know that avoid having you
know
data and student
records that may be stored on laptops
that can be lost that can be stolen so
having cloud-based solutions that
provide a high degree of security and
integrity
that that is an important technical
challenge to to keep in mind
many universities
are
moving to
you know what we would think about as a
more
centralized administration of technology
resources not dissimilar from what we
would see you know in other businesses
or large organizations
the net result being though
is
a college or school or department
may not have
organic
resources to provide technology support
all right so from the standpoint of
needing
what we would think of as kind of like
help desk type of support resources
many universities in many schools within
universities simply may not have those
additional resources so any technology
solution and again this is
i think favors cloud-based solutions
because it eliminates that necessity to
install software on individual computers
you know really helps address the
question of you know limited organic
technical support
and and then this last piece is also
such an important technical challenge
as
schools have gone
to you know the adoption of learning
management systems online course
management systems and leveraging
extensive
technology resources within what we
would even consider to be a regular
classroom based uh course
the
uh
requirement that these technology tools
really must work and play well with
others it is just absolutely paramount
in fact
if it doesn't that is a substantial
barrier to
adoption and so this could be you know
things like
working with zoom or panopto or canvas
you know some of these other platforms
but also
the ability to pass student records you
know student names student email
addresses single sign-on type solutions
all of these things are additional
requirements that
have now become
part of the student experience and so we
want to look for ways that minimize
friction points for students in adopting
new technologies
alright so those are some financial
those are some technical and then let me
talk about this not as a challenge
although for for some of my fellow
faculty members uh that may be listening
i think you can appreciate that
sometimes faculty um you know have
strong opinions you know while i'm i'm a
dean first and foremost i i feel that
i'm a professor first and so i can
appreciate the importance of of faculty
considerations and and these ones
that we're going to talk about
i would all put in a similar importance
category right
any kind of technology solutions and a
cloud solution for example must meet all
of these requirements so the first one
and this ties with you know what we just
talked about the importance of
integrating with
an online classroom management or
learning management solution right and
that could be as simple as ensuring that
links get populated into but also
that assignments that deliverables we'll
talk about grading in just a minute all
of those things can
be
put in one spot and easily accessed and
shared across multiple required
platforms
pedagogical flexibility
i think is another critical piece and
this would be you know for example let's
take in an analytics
course where you might have a faculty
member who prefers live coding
as you know a you know how they and
prefer to teach their course and so
they're going to be interacting with
students they're they're all going to be
coding at one time for example um that
is how the instructor would like to
interact with technology and deliver the
course you might have another faculty
member who prefers project-based work
that
you know classes are kind of meant for
discussion identifying some issues and
then students are going to go
on their own time work on projects
develop
you know deliverables and then bring
them back into
you know a course for discussion
ultimately the platform must be able to
have sufficient pedagogical flexibility
to really meet
faculty where they're at
and then today
when you think about instructional
materials it is very common for
textbooks
for other
kind of packaged curriculum products to
have a very kind of integrated approach
so
quizzes projects deliverables outside
readings everything kind of comes in a
package that the faculty member can
certainly you know adopt not adopt uh
you know kind of pick and choose but
there is kind of an expectation that
these things will all kind of work
together so when you think about
analytics textbooks for example you know
many of them today
are either tied to a software product
or you know so it could be microsoft
excel for example
or they are
they have examples across a wide variety
of technologies so you might see okay
here's how we we fit a regression line
using microsoft excel
and then in the appendix they would have
something in r and then potentially you
know python and you know stata and so
forth
so having
instructional materials that are kind of
built for the solution is a very
important consideration to encourage
faculty
adoption
modality flexibility
you know there's certainly as campuses
reopen you know coming out of the
pandemic we're certainly seeing more
students in class
which is a wonderful thing but
i think we're also
in an environment now where there is
significant expectations from students
that
they might engage with a wide variety of
classroom modalities
through a degree program so that could
be online asynchronous where it's
recorded lectures it's uh they're really
not interacting in any kind of live
way with an instructor but they're
they're going to have you know a heavy
online uh experience
all the way to you know a blended
classroom where you might have students
in a class
and online at the same time and you're
engaging in a fully synchronous
discussion in classroom activity so any
technology solution
needs to be
usable in a wide variety of
course modalities that reflects
where we are today as as an industry
you know student management
and really this is kind of as simple as
who's in my class and students are
already registering and in most cases
learning management systems get
pre-populated with students they reflect
students that add drop
you know at various points in the
semester uh you know faculty members
might go and create groups
you know in these environments
the ability to ensure that
faculty do not have to necessarily
duplicate processes
to ensure that students are added as
appropriately to a course
that is an important consideration as
would be for example the ability to
stack courses so let me give you an
example
as a scale question you might have
200 students in a semester taking an
introduction
to business analytics course and they
are in
four different sections that might be
taught in a variety of different
modalities maybe two sections are on
campus one section is online
asynchronous and another section is
online synchronous right so we have we
have multiple modalities we'll keep it
we'll keep it simple there's one
instructor but we have multiple
modalities we have 200 students
and some of those students are going to
add they're going to drop they're going
to be in groups
as a faculty member it's the same course
and so i might want to manage my
rstudio cloud
course portion
that is agnostic to which section the
student is in
so it's kind of one group of say 200 but
i need to be able to easily
manage the lists and manage grading
according to that individual
section structure
and now this would be
you know very similar to how you might
see an experience in canvas for example
where you're able to
to combine multiple independent sections
and manage them in one
uh in one area then the grading and
student feedback when we think about
the kind of the barriers to grading
courses
at scale so we've got 200 you know for
example
students are expecting you know a
reasonable degree of feedback and
interaction with an instructor and if
you have multiple deliverables you know
so let's say you have
five projects over the course of a
semester well that's a thousand
instances that must be graded and
returned to students now it could be the
case that
artificial intelligence machine learning
solutions kind of
automatic graders those are becoming you
know a little bit more common that could
be you know one possible
solution but ultimately the ability to
grade easily
and degrade quickly and to have those
grades move into
course management systems uh you know
that is a very important faculty
consideration so ensuring that
the
faculty member does not have to
duplicate a lot of
effort because anytime that that's the
case
faculty
adoption is likely to go down
substantially
okay so
let's then you know talk about what what
we have been doing
uh to to drive trains and drive
adoptions so and i want to i want to be
clear on a couple of things here
we
as a school we have a vision for where
we would like to go
but we are not yet at the point where we
are ready to simply turn on a
cloud-centric solution and make that our
de facto standard some of that is
you know reflects that cloud-based
analytics software including rstudio
cloud which is a wonderful product and
we've had a lot of success with it
is itself still developing
you know it doesn't have some of those
uh
you know technical capabilities that
would really allow us to
to think about using that package to
teach 2 000 students per year in a with
a very
you know faculty friendly and
student-friendly way that doesn't mean
that
the product doesn't continue to advance
and get stronger it absolutely is but
it's not quite ready yet but neither is
really anybody else so it's it's also
kind of important to keep that in mind
the technology itself is still
developing
um
but this first bullet point when we
think about driving change and
using cloud-based solutions for for
analytics instruction it has to be
faculty-centric faculty have to be
driving it
and there needs to be a critical mass of
faculty that are saying
not just we want to use this product
but we feel that this product is better
than alternatives
and it's better because
we can do more in our course
we can lower student friction and
increase student experience if we use
this product
right and i think that that message that
critical mass from faculty is such a
critical piece
to this you know from administration
kind of
pushing down to faculty you know you
will you will now start using this
uh to teach your courses is not likely
to be a a productive approach instead
it's more of a bottom-up
you know the necessity of a bottom-up
which might require some additional
faculty education and you know if you
have faculty who have you know been you
know very used and very comfortable with
teaching with a particular technology in
a particular way
you know they might they might be
willing to make the shift and and adopt
you know you know in this case a
cloud-based solution but that's going to
require rethinking their course
potentially rethinking deliverables and
learning the new set you know software
product themselves and so the importance
of having faculty education to help them
see how they can use this technology to
make their course better that is a
critical part
it's also helpful you know for those
faculty members who are you know say
tenure track or you know they have a
strong research component
there's certainly value in having a
connection to their research technology
and i think this is an advantage for our
uh in our studio because of the adoption
in academia of both r and r studio an
advantage of our studio cloud is the
interface
of the cloud product is effectively a
mirror image of the interface of the
desktop product and so likely to already
have some faculty
with some comfort in r and r studio but
that's certainly not universal if i have
a faculty member
for example in finance who is very used
to stata
and i'm trying to encourage you know him
or her to think about rstudio cloud as
an alternative you know that faculty
member may very reasonably say you know
i i know how to use this product
i'm very comfortable with it i you know
i'd rather just not teach the course
that you want me to teach if i can't use
the technology that i'm most comfortable
with because that's my research
uh is all tied into that existing um
uh
you know into an existing platform so
you know important to kind of keep in
mind um
that you know a research connection
that would be ideal but but certainly
not um certainly not a requirement
um
it's also you know in any kind of
organizational change initiative you
know having senior leadership support uh
is is important but i would i would add
a little bit of a caveat to this you
know certainly
having you know a cio or chief data
officer or or e-learning officer that is
supportive of the technology that that
is very valuable
but i would say it's more the
instructional leadership so deans
provosts
chief academic officers you know those
who have the direct connection to
faculty
that can help address faculty concerns
but also provide you know incentives and
support
to
encourage faculty to
use this technology
to improve their courses
right and then you know certainly you
know creative financial solutions
by creative
you know universities are generally
under budget and cost pressures from a
variety of different ways that is not
likely to
um
mitigate in any meaningful way over the
next decade um
you know certainly varies by
uh you know geographic area uh and
around the world but i think it's
probably safe to say that on balance
cost pressures are going to be
um you know a meaningful consideration
for
not just for a university that might be
looking at adopting this technology but
certainly also for students with the
increased cost of higher education so
you know always kind of keeping in mind
you know sometimes it's a lot easier to
solve the technology barriers than it is
to solve the financial barriers but
solving the financial barriers um
you know is uh is certainly a key
requirement
so that is uh
that is it for
uh the conversation that i had i i know
there's been some some chat going
um
but i certainly would like to uh you
know extend the opportunity for any
questions that anybody in the audience
might have or
or uh pete i see you coming back on the
screen great to see you again if there
are some other questions or
opportunities to expand
thanks brian that uh that was super
insightful uh just like all the times
leading up to this that we spoke i took
a ton of notes
um so i really appreciate that let's uh
see if we have any questions coming in
live if not then i will
throw some of my my own uh in to get the
conversation started further
let me just double check
and and would certainly echo the uh the
observation in the chat it's it's
wonderful to see so many folks from
around the world joining us
absolutely uh love seeing that so i'm
having a little tech issue getting the
questions to show up on the screen
because apparently my questions are too
long but uh
not to worry i'll just read through them
so the first one i had was um you know
the idea that you are appointed as dean
but but you're also a professor do you
think that the fact that you do have
that that dean appointment um
kind of changes your experience adopting
a solution like cloud compared to
someone that
might be a professor only
you know that's a great question peter
and the short answer is is certainly yes
um uh you know i think from from an
individual standpoint you know because
you occupy a leadership role um
you the the approval process if you will
is is a little bit streamlined because
you're the approver
so
from the standpoint of being able to to
pilot and try things out i think in our
case
we were able to to do more
experimentation and and that
experimentation started in my own class
and using rstudio cloud in my class to
kind of teach it in a different way and
then i was able to use my own experience
in working with other faculty
about how you know you know you know
successes that i had challenges that i
observed student friction points
but then also being able to
uh
you know speed up approval processes
because i was then an advocate for
other faculty wanting to use
wanting to use the product
great
um
now when you mention the the current
stack uh that you
um that you had used
i think you you used the term employer
need um and that kind of uh helped drive
uh which tools were going to be used
curious um kind of how you got that
feedback i don't know if it was through
alumni or through various employers in
industry that you might keep in contact
with but what does that process look
like
no that's a that's another good question
i think and i think business schools
you know are are able to have that
dialogue
with employers um in a more organic way
for example than other units that might
exist at on a university campus because
we are so connected
with the business community i mean you
know that is our our mission and so we
generally have our own career services
teams we have you know various advisory
boards we you know are interacting with
alums on a very regular basis and so
there's kind of a continuous dialogue
that happens as a result of simply being
you know existing to serve the employer
community but i think one of the the
uh
one tool that we use quite
extensively is through our career
services you know team but also you can
do this with with other available
sources is job postings
and so within our region
so
within our region and for
positions and employers who are not
necessarily hiring you know a
substantial number of what we would
think about data scientists but do
require
new hires to have broad analytics
experience what are some of the
technologies that they are asking for i
think a good example here is a bank
right so certainly a bank will will be
hiring most banks today will be hiring a
certain number of data science
scientists for you know very heavy
technical jobs but
you know a commercial lender
right a
uh
an investment manager you know these
individuals are now expected to have
you know a at least some level of
competency in a variety of technologies
and and this is where you know our
python sql have kind of risen to the top
and then from a data visualization
standpoint tableau and power bi
interesting
i just noticed that some folks are
actually asking about your slides i
don't know if you're open to sharing
that and if so there's a good place for
for people to find them
uh yes absolutely and so perhaps uh you
know pete what might be helpful is i i
will send these to you and then you can
put them on the uh the website for the
event would that be helpful
absolutely happy to um work offline on
that uh so if folks are listening we
will definitely get brian slides out
there and brian thanks for being open to
sharing those absolutely um
so
i i believe earlier you you mentioned
that
there's
this um
this perspective of having having a
cohesive tool set so when you think of
um
professors that might have a use case
that's targeted purely for undergrads
and others that might uh be looking at a
graduate education program or maybe you
know there's there's those out there
that kind of have to think about both uh
do you think it makes um
you know a lot of sense to ensure that
what you're using in undergrad um is
going to be similar to what they're
going to experience at the graduate
level
any thoughts on that
no um
i think this touches a little bit on
that that student experience and
consistency of student experience
you know some technologies are better
equipped for than others
for the different student populations
you know and particularly if you think
about you know undergraduate programs
that might be targeted to you know
particular student population and then
graduate programs that you know are
targeted to a very different you know
student population
you know
some
products
uh you know some analytics products are
better equipped than others
that to kind of address
differences in those student populations
so
you know for for example um
you know the sas you know uh is an
example of a product that you know very
robust very powerful analytics product
but
the the
the learning curve if you will
is probably a little bit steeper than
what you would
what would be ideally suited for an
undergraduate student population with
that might have substantial variation in
in
technology preparation you know and
literacy
whereas a graduate program could be
perfectly appropriate to to use in that
context so i think
as we've been thinking about it are
there some products that
are
flexible enough
such that you can design
you know course experiences that align
with the different
student populations and so
and this is where i think we've had some
success with the the r studio cloud
product for example where we're using it
in
an mba class that is all about data
wrangling it's it's what what would you
consider to be a very
analytics
heavy
course
with a high degree of technology
sophistication but then
we are also using it in an executive mba
course
that you know these are individuals who
absolutely are not from strong
technology backgrounds they are senior
leaders
they are not interested in getting into
the nuts and bolts of learning
programming but we're still able to use
the technology to
you know create an accessible
you know student experience so i think
that's the
the overarching criteria pete is
student experience
and ensuring that the
the technology solution doesn't
create friction
in that experience and then if you can
allow for consistency across
then even better
that makes a ton of sense um
so good news uh we have some questions
from the audience trickling in uh so
thanks for bearing with me there the
first one it looks like it says can you
speak more to teaching business students
analytics we are developing similar
programs and need to differentiate from
data science
you know this this is such an important
criteria and we struggled with this
uh as well and it gets to that notion
that we talked about who what service
what population do we want to serve do
we want to serve
data scientists and give them
you know business skills and business
toolkits or do we want to train business
professionals with analytics skill sets
and i think that difference was how we
helped communicate not just to students
but also external stakeholders and
senior university leadership that we
need technology solutions that help
business professionals understand
analytics so they need to be
accessible they need to be grounded in a
business context from and by by business
context this is what businesses are
using
you know the the this is this the tool
kit that we are finding in business and
business students need to have
experience with this toolkit so let me
give kind of a contrast you might find
in a statistics department that the
department makes heavy use of matlab
software you know for example very
robust excellent
statistics and mathematics software you
are not going to go find that
in use in industry
and so i think part of it is
ensuring that the
technology
aligns to what employers are expecting
and then ground it in that business
context so to the question about you
know teaching you know business students
analytics
gearing it towards business problems
so
you know
we we might find
you know a textbook uh you know
statistics textbook might have a toy
problem about
you know maybe it's a health care issue
or something like that we might change
that and say okay we're going to do a an
analysis of employee compensation
or we're going to do an analysis of
customer satisfaction and we're going to
build a predictive model of customer
churn
you know the technology and the
curriculum is centered around a business
problem
in a very applied way
thank you brian
the next question here looks like we're
able to put it on the screen
there we go
i wonder about the partnership between
administration i.t and faculty rit has
limited ability to implement remote and
cloud resources
yeah yeah absolutely
i think this is where vendors can play a
role
uh that you know the nice thing about
cloud-based products is you're already
you're already not talking about
adding existing
uh
you know hardware or software
requirements to the campus it
environment
so
you've already kind of removed that
constraint which is which is important
i think the other piece of it is
vendors providing robust
technology support that is geared
towards faculty and making it very
simple for
the
uh
for it staff to deal with
this new
tool that faculty want to use in the
classroom so you know for example
you know apis that vendors have
developed
to create plug-ins and we we've talked
about this in the past pete would to
you know plug into canvas
that the uh you know that
plug into various erp systems that are
used for student records and grading
i would say
those are things that vendors need to
take the lead on providing because
schools just are not going to have
the resources or the desire to take on
that that product if if it's well listen
you're gonna have to figure out we'll
we'll we'll export the student records
but you're gonna have to figure it out
that's you know that that is not going
to be
um
you know that's gonna create additional
barriers to uh to adoption and so this
notion of partnership
uh i i think is very critical i would
put faculty as as need to lead
administration needs to be champions and
and i t needs to not be a barrier
and and i i don't mean that in the
context that you know
you know i t teams are barriers right
they have a they have a tough job to do
um you know they're dealing with a lot
of things you know increasingly uh
budgets are very constrained they're you
know lots of competition for talent
it's
making it very easy for them to
support this technology and in some
cases that could be they don't need to
support it really
at all
interesting you know what that's a
question and topic that comes up often
um
when i'm in various conversations with
institutions so uh definitely resonates
well with me uh whoever asked that
question thank you
so next up thanks for the great talk
where can one go to start experimenting
with our studio in the cloud in our own
classroom
so
there's a few options probably the best
ones at the top there you can go to that
link there's a free version that's not
um you know featured gated or anything
you can also feel free to email me
directly and we can go into
you know particular use cases
looks like we're coming uh to the end of
our time but we do have
yeah i can just add on that one of the
the very helpful resources that you guys
have put together
in the um in the help section of our
studio cloud are examples of using cloud
in the classroom so
the ability to create assignments for
example is um you know that's a great
resource i'd also say the
that
uh all of the um the cheat sheets for
our studio you know that are also kind
of very easy i found that students very
much appreciate having access to those
cheat sheets and help resources all
within the cloud so i think you'll find
it you know for those faculty who want
to just kind of experiment with it i
think you'll find it fairly accessible
absolutely
thanks for pointing that out the cheat
sheets are super popular um down to the
last minute it looks like we have one
last question here
on the financial constraints of adopting
solutions is it possible to teach how to
do
financial analysis for example with r
and what about employment opportunities
with this route
so i mean in terms of the content
uh you know teaching financial analysis
or ratio analysis or some of these you
know teaching an accounting class for
example an r and everything that that
goes with it yes you could absolutely do
that um i would kind of balance that
with the expectation for excel skills um
you know just from an industry
standpoint
but it is possible to do a lot of things
like that in our and i would say
opportunities to find
um
complementary uses of technologies
within some of these more uh
you know what it would kind of consider
to be more quantitatively sophisticated
courses uh you know are useful so you
you might have you know modules that
have students working in an excel
product um you know they're doing you
know different kind of analyses
different kind of works but then okay
you're going to move it into r and
you're going to do you know more
sophisticated predictive modeling or
things like that and you're going to use
these tools complementary um
you know that's that's a pretty powerful
uh
combination and that's something that
we're going to be doing in some of our
accounting classes uh is starting next
fall
exciting
well it looks like we're coming to a
close uh for today so thanks again uh to
brian and all of you for joining uh if
you have the time i'm going to throw
this up on the screen right now there is
a event tomorrow a virtual event where
our colleague amine will actually be
running through
some rstudio cloud best practices
and uh this will be during a keynote
and then in the new year we're going to
be having our next event for this live
online series
so till then happy holidays and bye for
now
thanks everybody thank you